so thanks very much for inviting me and
i'm so sorry i can't be there
in person um
i always joke that you know i'm
an affiliate in philosophy and you can
always tell the difference between my
philosophy talks and my psychology talks
because the philosophy ones don't have
any data and have really terrible power
points so you're going to get a
philosophy talk this time instead of a
psychology talk although i'll have a
little bit of data and this is a bunch
of new ideas that i've had recently
they'll actually be in an essay that
will be in the wall street journal on
saturday and i can send it or you can
look at it on the wall street journal on
saturday uh
uh okay so as we all know and as i'm
sure people have been talking have been
discussing here um
recently there was a brouhaha about
whether lambda which is one of these
large language models was actually a
sentient intelligent agent
and pretty much everybody except this
google engineer said that they weren't
but of course the debate was a debate
about whether or not lambda was an
intelligent agent and a lot of debates
about our recent advances in ai have
that character so is it in fact the case
that they ate the uh uh an ai system um
particularly a large language model is
you know a genius like alan turing or is
it just a deceptive
double top bull artist like the famous
professor or corey who i highly suggest
you go and look up on on youtube uh
double talk artists were people who
learned how to just produce a string of
words that sounded like they made sense
but didn't actually um and some people
have argued that gbt3 or the large
language models are more like that but
what i want to argue is that that's the
wrong way of thinking about it that it
especially for large language models and
for lots of recent ai um
the view of thinking of them by
comparison with an individual agent is
just the wrong way of thinking about
them and instead what i want to argue is
that we should think about these systems
especially the large language models as
being cultural technologies what do i
mean by cultural technology i mean a
technology that allows humans to access
and summarize and use all the other
knowledge um and discoveries that other
humans have made over the over the
generations
uh so it's not a technology that itself
is intelligent but it's one that's sort
of essential for human intelligence
because it allows humans to access the
intelligence of other humans and you
could make a good argument that the sort
of er example of this is language itself
which enables us to say
tell another hunter that we found game
or it lets a grandmother and
grandmothers are probably very much the
relevant category here pass on
information uh about uh foraging to the
next generation um
uh writing is so language is sort of the
er example of this kind of cultural
technology
but i think there's a good argument that
much of human progress has been the
result of changes and progress in these
cultural technologies so writing itself
is another example of something that now
enables you not only to
access the knowledge of the people close
to you but the knowledge of people who
are hundreds of years past or or
hundreds of miles away um and print
obviously turns up the dial on writing
so once you have print you can access
even more information from even more
people and there's good reason to
believe that print was responsible for
the enlightenment for liberal democracy
for a lot of the changes for
industrialization for a lot of the
changes in the in the long 18th century
um
uh libraries are another example of kind
of cultural technology that enables us
to access more information and of course
more recently we have the very
phenomenon of internet search itself and
phenomenal like wikipedia that are also
these technologies that don't actually
produce knowledge or information
themselves but give us more efficient
ways of accessing the knowledge or
information that other people
before us or in different places have
actually produced
and it's just wrong to think about these
cultural technologies as like agents so
you know asking whether lambda is
intelligent or not is like asking
whether the university of california
berkeley library is intelligent or not
or whether google search knows the
answer to your questions or not it's
just the wrong category um and what i
want to argue is that lambda and other
ais are this kind of a thing this kind
of a technology not what you might think
of as a classic artificial intelligence
in say robotics where you're actually
trying to design uh an independent agent
that will go out into the world and be
intelligent
now that is not at all to minimize the
importance of these technologies um in
fact there's a pretty strong argument of
p made by people like dick boyd and
peter richardson and joseph henrik that
that cultural ability the ability to
have cultural technologies is exactly
what makes humans special so other
animals do pass on information from
generation to generation to some extent
but none of them does it in the way that
we do and to the extent that we do and
certainly for as long over many
generations as we do and there's a good
argument that it's exactly that ability
to take on information from previous
generations that enables us to uh to
function as well as we do you could
paraphrase newton and say all of us are
standing on the shoulders of all of
those who have come before us um so
adding a cultural technology actually
makes a big difference to uh to human
intelligence um
and of course what large language models
do and other ai models like imagenet or
or or dali do is not produce language
themselves what they do is summarize
billions and billions and billions of
sentences that have been placed out on
the web by other humans
uh
all right so what's missing if if in
fact what's most important for human
intelligence is this transfer of
knowledge and belief from one generation
to another uh
why not say that uh gpg3 or lambda is is
intelligent well this process of
cultural evolution as people call it in
uh in evolut in biology and psychology
depends on a balance between two
different processes they're typically
described as imitation versus innovation
so the idea is that one part of cultural
evolution is that you take on the
information
and the practices of the people before
you through imitation and as many people
have pointed out something like uh like
lambda is a super imitator that's really
what it's doing it's just doing a
massively good job of imitating the
patterns that it sees out there in the
world of text um but then
doing that imitation wouldn't be worth
anything it wouldn't help you unless
there were people who were also
innovating unless there were generations
that were also going beyond just what
the previous generation had done to go
out and actually explore the world find
things not that are expected but things
that are unexpected find things that are
novel and of course again lambda works
by saying here's what the most likely
thing would be given this uh this here's
the most likely continuation given in
this text and in fact for innovation
what you need to do is do just the
opposite you need to look out for things
that are unexpected that you wouldn't
have thought of in the first place and
here's where my tiny bit of empirical
work has come i've argued that children
and childhood in particular are really
well designed for this innovation niche
as well as the imitation niche and in an
experiment that we just recently
published on archive um
what we did was actually look at causal
learning in particular which is
something i've been looking at for the
last 20 years really really important
way of learning about the world maybe
the most important way that humans live
independently learn about the world
through exploration and trying to find
cause and effect relationships
and what we did was just design a very
simple set of tasks with an online
blicket detector the blicket detector is
the way that we found out about
causation and the way this works is you
just put things on the detector and the
detector lights up sometimes and not
others and you have to figure out how it
works and the uh criterion for how it
works is that at the end we ask the kids
and we do this with three and four and
five-year-olds um
tell me which one is a blicket the
blickets make it go and see if you can
make it work yourself
so it's it's quite a simple task but
children turn out to be extremely good
at it even very young children are very
good at
making inferences about the structure
and we thought this is such a simple
task that surely in those billions of
texts that uh that something like gpt3
is using there should be the information
that you need to know what the right
consequence of what the right answer to
these questions are um and there is some
work and some evidence that in some
contexts um something like jpt can can
do
everyday reasoning but again there's a
lot of everyday reasoning already
embedded in the text that it's learning
from and in fact no one had ever seen
this particular machine with this
particular structure with this
particular pattern before in all of
those texts and all of that time until
the children are actually seeing it
so what we discovered was even in this
online setting which is kind of
interesting in and of itself the
children are very good at exploring
they'll try different kinds of
combinations and try and test them do
kind of everyday experiments and in
about 20 trials they solve the problem
we also tested sort of state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning mechanisms on
this and they take about 150 000 trials
to solve this problem and uh here's an
example of a child actually playing with
it so you can see how uh you can see how
it works
um
and you know in terms of innovation as i
said i think it's interesting 20 years
ago when we started doing this work the
kids would not have been happy about
doing this on a computer screen and now
they're perfectly happy about doing it
on a computer screen um
but when we gave it not only to gpt 3
but also to palm
which is the even more recent and uh and
more powerful version
they were surprisingly bad at it and it
was only if we gave them specific
training about this is a blicket and
this isn't that they did well at all
um
okay so that suggests that it gpt 3
isn't doing everything that you would
want to do to have intelligence
intelligence depends both on being able
to access information from the past and
being able to innovate and do things in
the future now as i was saying the the
prevailing view about the evolution of
human intelligence is that this kind of
cultural technology is really crucial to
that intelligence that raises the
question okay is having is uh uh
is turning up the capacity for cultural
technologies a good thing or a bad thing
and
going back you know it's good in the
sense that that's what we evolved to do
but going all the way back in human
history there's always been both sides
so the fact given humans racist sexist
and irrational and biased and have all
these problems in their cognition
depending on the cognition and knowledge
and beliefs of other people is always
going to be this double-edged sword
because on the one hand you're going to
get the information about where the game
is but on the other hand and
evolutionary biologists have argued this
um there's now an incentive for the
other hunter to mislead you about where
the game is so he can get all the game
uh himself
and
with each iteration of new cultural
technologies this tension between
getting the truth from other people and
being deceived by other people has has
been uh uh has been a feature of of the
cultural changes themselves and as i'm
sure everybody here knows famously for
example socrates thought that writing
was a really bad idea for cultural
transmission um it's funny because i
actually found this uh this quote and it
could be talking about gbt3 because he
says they seem to talk to you as though
they were intelligent this is him
socrates talking about written books
um but ask them anything about what they
say they'll just go on telling you
they'll go on telling you just the same
thing forever
so socrates is describing written books
in a way that sounds very much like the
way that we might describe uh uh gpt3 it
just goes on telling you the same thing
the same thing forever and socrates is
contrasting that with socratic dialogues
famously so-called where you're dealing
with a real live person and you can
alter and change and respond to what the
person has asked you
uh print is another nice example of a
technology that both had positive and
negative consequences so this is
actually a picture of benjamin franklin
um
uh who was famously was a printer and
uh and franklin and the other founders
uh other enlightenment figures used the
innovations that made printing much
cheaper and much easier in the 18th
century to actually spread the word
about things like liberal democracy and
those
you know arguably changes like the
american revolution couldn't have
happened without this cheap pamphlet
technology um on the other hand robert
dotton many years ago pointed out that
the same kinds of technologies in the
case of france also produced large
amounts of obscenity and libel and
really you know stuff that's so horrible
that it would put even the current you
know put even twitter to shame um and
indeed was responsible for some of the
worst features of the french revolution
so that's another example of where the
two the two you have get the two sides
of cultural technologies and cultural
evolution
um
and the way that people have dealt with
this over the years is that as each of
these cultural technologies emerges
there's a new set of norms rules
regulations laws this is something that
i know you've been talking about in this
group
that emerged to deal with this
double-edged sword of cultural evolution
um and we've shown an empirical evidence
that even
very young children even four-year-olds
uh have norms about being truthful so
for example if you have someone lie to a
kid several times they'll stop trusting
that person so they're already using
information about the past uh about the
past testimony and reliability of past
testimony to make new inferences and
there's a whole
giant bunch of evidence that suggests
that that's true
um so this is even with three and
four-year-olds and then we have
institutions like testifying under oath
we have
uh new categories of people
like editors or journalism professors or
journalism schools
fact checkers we have new laws libel
laws uh privacy laws defamation suits
and so forth
it wouldn't make any sense to have had a
fact checker before you actually had uh
before you had print it wouldn't make
any sense to have a fact checker in the
context of uh say an oral society
um so i think the punchline which i
imagine is kind of a punchline here as
well
is that it's we shouldn't be thinking
about these things in terms of is this
you know the golem who's going to come
and kill us all in our beds because it
will become an ascension agent i think
you might want to worry about that but
one of the things i say is as a mother
one of the things you learn how to do is
ration your worries to the ones that are
going to be worse
but you certainly could worry about the
potential effects of a new form of
cultural technology a new form of
cultural evolution and do all the kinds
of things that you uh that we've done in
the past to make sure that that cultural
technology uh is ends up being uh
beneficent instead of malign and i'll
stop there
okay thanks
uh sticking right on 15 minutes so thank
you
uh i think we'll jump to
our second speaker now uh who will go on
for about 15 minutes again then we'll do
a group q a
so